holidays over and it was a charity night
out for Harry and Megan at the musical
Hamilton it has been a summer of high
drama the couple with her family making
sure they've really been out of the
headlines tauros Kendall Black is still
one of their loyal supporters but what
about the soap opera surrounding her
family it doesn't really bother me I
think it makes her more humble appearing
and it makes her seem more down-to-earth
and she's from a dysfunctional family
like we all are and I think most of what
her dad and her half-sister have said
it's really just sensationalist news to
try and just get money in a string of
interviews Megan's dad has criticized
his daughter for not being in touch told
us he's fallen out with his son-in-law
and had a go at the royal family it
hasn't been the ideal start to married
life I think it's definitely affecting
perceptions of the couple and the real
the real danger is that this becomes the
story that defines them in the same way
that the split between Charles and Diana
in the night in 1990s became a story
that overshadowed everything else they
did at the time ahead of their fairytale
big day you could see that Megan's
relationship with her family wasn't
straightforward and it ended up with her
father not coming to the wedding
Kensington Palace insisted they had
tried to offer him support the palace
have been criticized for how they've
handled all of this and some have even
described it as a crisis but in some
ways their hands are tied it is up to
their boss Prince Harry to decide how to
handle the press and in the end only
Megan can decide what's the next step
when it comes to her father so Megan is
very much kind of like the star of the
moment at Elle magazine they published
articles written by Megan before she met
Harry our audience have been with her
since the beginning because she has
written for us so I think they're really
about the woman more so about the
scandal and a lot of the comments have
been really quite sympathetic to her you
know a lot of women who read l feel
quite you know sorry for her in terms of
like being a newlywed having to deal
with this family strife thank you and to
all you guys thank you so much
that was spectacular a stage show about
fighting against the odds feels rather
appropriate with those family problems
behind the scenes they will want to
change that storyline away from private
matters and back to what they want to
achieve in their public life together
Rhiannon Mills Sky News